[Musique]
avec Julien chaïda bonjour Julien
bonjour Damien on va commencer cette
revue de presse par cette annonce qui a
fait beaucoup couler d'encre ces
dernières 24 heures celle de
l'attribution des Jeux d'hiver
asiatiques tenez vous bien à l'Arabie
Saoudite ça ressemble un petit peu
Damien a un conte de fées façon Reine
des Neiges mais tout des tout dépend du
point de vue duquel on se place regardez
ces images publiées à la une du
quotidien golfnews il s'appelle le
projet je cite troiana implanté dans la
ville ultra futuriste de NEOM il ne
s'agit pas du scénario du futur matrix
ce bien une véritable histoire cette
cité entièrement verticale vous la voyez
ici et ici qui sera donc bâti dans les
montagnes saoudiennes au beau milieu du
désert alors oui là oui il fait
peut-être 2000 il fait peut-être un peu
froid à 2600 mètres d'altitude mais ce
n'est pas suffisant pour aller skier
l'Arabie Saoudite était déjà en train de
construire cette cité du futur qui va
quand même coûter la bagatelle d'environ
500 milliards de dollars vous voyez
surtout un projet qui dépasse
l'entendement sur le plan environnement
euh Jérôme valqueux témoigne il revient
longuement sur les coulisses de
l'attribution de cette candidature
qatari il dit qu'il n'y a pas de
corruption qui les prouvé à l'heure
actuelle il y a plusieurs ouvertes
notamment par leur parquet national
financier de Paris il met il évoque des
soupçons de favoritisme à des fins
politiques et évoquant notamment les
noms de Michel Platini et Nicolas
Sarkozy tiens donc dans ce constat dans
ce contexte plusieurs villes françaises
ont fait le choix de boycoter cette
Coupe du Monde oui pas de Fan Zone ni
d'écran géants dans plusieurs grandes
villes comme l'île Strasbourg Bordeaux
ou encore Paris bon il faut dire qu'à
l'automne c'est pas vraiment le moment
propice pour aller regarder des matchs
en plein air mais c'est surtout pour
protester contre les conditions
d'organisation on l'a dit de cette coupe
du monde mais mais real politique obéit
certains élus comme les verdonis
Christian Estrosi ne s'interdit pas de
revenir sur cette question en cas de bon
parcours de l'équipe de France on prend
la direction du Royaume-Uni maintenant
avec ce discours de clôture de la
première ministre britannique listraus à
la convention du parti conservateur et
les presse la presse qui s'interroge si
ce ne sera pas déjà son dernier discours
avec une question qui s'affiche en Une
de métro et cette photo fantastique je
le dis est-ce qu'elle peut y arriver la
première ministre liseuse qui a pris le
poste il y a peine un mois et déjà dans
la tourmente après la présentation de
son plan qui était qui était voué à
contrer l'inflation galopante au
Royaume-Uni plan qui malheureusement a
provoqué la chute de la livre sterling
et c'est dans ce contexte que le Parti
travailliste dans l'opposition depuis 12
ans est à la tête dans les sondages et
rêve déjà d'élection anticipée le New
York Times lui pose une question
beaucoup plus provocatrice comment
a-t-elle pu faire autant de dégâts en si
peu de temps pour l'éditorialiste Paul
krugmann prix Nobel de la Paix
d'économie au passage la première
ministre a perdu toute crédibilité en
présentant un plan je cite irresponsable
avec notamment la réduction drastique
des impôts des plus fortunés pour
soi-disant relancer la croissance
plusieurs responsables dit-il on a
encore jamais connu depuis la bronca de
son propre parti et bien les stress a
fait machine arrière sur quelques points
mais il en va de son arrêté selon ses
proches et elle ne compte pas revenir
entièrement sur ses propositions et
c'est peut-être cette attitude qui fait
dire avait independante que les stress
sera peut-être la seule responsable de
son éventuel chute on y est pas encore
mais plusieurs voix conservatrices
estiment qu'il serait peut-être bon pour
tout le monde qu'elle s'en aille autre
chose en France maintenant on
s'interroge sur la place des écrans dans
la vie de nos enfants et leur impact oui
évidemment il est plus rapide d'écrire
un courriel on sait que d'envoyer une
lettre manuscrite mais ce n'est quand
même pas une raison pour bannir le stylo
le Parisien livre un grand dossier que
je vous invite à lire avec cette
question un peu provocatrice est-ce
qu'écrire à la main c'est encore utile
et bien oui répondre les pédiatres car
il y a un lien évident entre le geste
graphique et la compréhension de ce
qu'on fait autrement dit le cerveau
quand on écrit et dans l'action et non
dans la simple opération dans la simple
observation pardon comme avec un écran
voilà et quand on écrit à la main et
puis on apprend en même temps avant de
se quitter on fait un détour par les
États-Unis ou un petit français petit
est au centre de toutes les attentions
les petites me retenez ce nom Victor
whenba nyama joueur de basket du Bologne
Levallois 94 avec son club francilien il
effectue une tournée d'exhibition aux
États-Unis à l'invitation de la grande
NBA mais là-bas tous les yeux sont
arrivés non pas sur le club mais sur ce
Français qui vous le disait n'est pas si
petit mais finalement assez grand hein
on le voit ici sur cette photo 2m21
difficile de le manquer effectivement
chaque éloigné pour comparaison c'était
de mettre 26 à peu près les Américains
ne cachent pas que c'est surtout lui
qu'ils ont invité les collègues de son
club apprécieront merci beaucoup Julien
j'ai d'abord cette revue